these are faces amongst hundreds of
others who fought for freedom but will
not live to see it
since September the Islamic Republic of
Iran saw the largest and most radical
anti-regime protests in its 43-year
history it was sparked by the death of
22 year old Masa amini in the custody of
the so-called morality police
her crime not wearing her hijab properly
now at least outwardly life appears to
have returned back to normal and some 22
000 demonstrators were arrested have
recently been pardoned over the past few
months I've been speaking to some of the
protesters inside of Iran investigating
different aspects of the movement they
tell me that although the public unrest
has quietened down at least on the
surface the fire is still very much
burning beneath the ashes people can't
stay on the streets forever the movement
is far from over things are only getting
started
of course we can't think that A
revolution is going to happen in just
three months this is something that will
take time because it's also a cultural
issue Mahmoud Raha and Sarah their names
have been changed to protect their
identities they're all in their twenties
and are taking action in the uprising
the process here of changed form people
are continuing the unrest through
graffitis burning street signs taking
down CCTV cameras and planning other
forms of attack
[Music]
dictator and women life Freedom are
heard from apartment windows
and social media is flooded with other
acts of protest like this group of girls
in a Tehran neighborhood a dangerous
Defiance of the country's strict
morality laws
they appear to be apologizing
this art installation in a Tehran
University is amongst many others
showing descent if you were to gather
all the blood that's been shed you could
fill up a big pool and that's what we
did with red paint
in Response Security came and physically
attacked us
the monitoring of the hijab has also
been tightened
we now have hijab security at the
University's entrance if we're showing
too much hair they don't allow us in if
we get a second warning then we can get
excluded from the University
but away from the security we drop our
headscarves all three risk torture
imprisonment and even death for just
speaking with me but Mahmoud is adamant
to share his experience
one evening the anti-protest police
raided us I was running away when I
heard a motorbike behind me then he shot
me Mahmoud avoided arrest but was left
seriously wounded
footage given exclusively to Sky News
reveals the extent of his injuries he'd
been hit by pellets from a gun
I had around 250 pellets inside me after
four hours in the operating table Medics
only managed to pull out around 30.
Mahmoud was told that the rest would
have to remain in his body meaning he's
unable to leave the country I now
constantly live in fear of being
identified in case someone sees my scars
I cannot go through any metal detecting
Gates because the metal left in my body
could identify me as a protester I would
be looking at anything between years of
imprisonment to even execution and those
fears aren't unfounded there has been a
series of force confessions Hasty trials
and four public executions
the ruthless tactics carried out by the
regime are clear many believe that is
the regime's brutal and deadly Crackdown
that has played a significant role in
the unrest becoming quieter
the people protesting now are much fewer
than before and it makes me feel like
I'm alone
but this doesn't mean that the
movement's over
students have been at the Forefront of
the movement calling for freedom it was
really bad in University they kept
calling the students on private numbers
it was the security police
and across Iran schools are being
targeted too since November hundreds of
school children mostly girls have fallen
ill as a result of a suspected gas
poisoning by the regime a statement they
strongly deny but Raha Sarah and Mahmoud
aren't detailed by these intimidation
tactics
you can't keep scaring people forever
there is only one way forward and that's
a revolution
when we know the law protects us instead
of oppressing us then we will have the
freedom to claim our rights many people
are doing their part as they want to
change and their life to get better not
like what we're currently living we
can't even call this life
Street demonstrations may have ease for
now but daring this place of public
Defiance remain and as the regime
desperately tries to conceal traces of
their disobedience the protesters
persist the regime Moscow
Sahar sand Sky News